c'est dans le somptueux jardin de l'état
à saint denis ce jeudi 28 juillet que le
capitaine tiffany graal rendait le
fanion de la 5e compagnie de formation
professionnelle au colonel jean vincent
berthe chef de corps elle cède sa place
au capitaine jean-pierre bonizzoni
j'étais responsable du bon déroulement
de la formation professionnelle au sein
de la 5e compagnie qui est situé à el
rey à saint denis au quartier el rey
nous formons des agents de prévention et
de sécurité des garçons serveur en
restauration et quatre filières de
formation professionnelle d'un métier du
bâtiment les menuiseries la menuiserie
aluminium le nizerhy en bâtiment des
monteurs dépanneur en froid et
climatisation est également des
plaquistes maintenant je vais partir
vers d'autres vers d'autres horizons à
paris et poursuivre sa scolarité
c'est un moment intense parce que ça
clôt sur deux ans de deux ans de travail
deux ans d'implication et
une cérémonie au cours de laquelle on
passe le flambeau en transmet le
flambeau parce que nous sommes que de
passage et on transmet le flambeau à son
successeur
ça fait 1 évidemment un pincement au
coeur puisque je quitte un métier je
quitte des gens voient là et je quitte
une île aussi sa rentrée le capitaine
bonizzoni passe donc à la tête d'une des
plus importantes unités du rsm a basé au
quartier el rey à saint denis
il aura pour mission de contribuer à
former et à insérer plus de 400 jeunes
volontaires stagiaires réunionnais
j'espère y apporter
ma contribution pour l'emploi des jeunes
réunionnais en les
en arrivant les insérer au mieux dans la
vie active réunionnaise pouvoir en
métropole
le capitaine tiffany grall a elle même
choisi le jardin de l'état pour cette
cérémonie
une première pour cet équipement du
département qui n'avait encore jamais
accueilli une passation de commandement
alors la cérémonie est organisée par le
capitaine g donc la personne à qui je
succède en tout cas c'est un endroit
magnifique et la météo était avec nous
donc je suis très content de l'avoir
fait ici c'est un site magnifique un
site verdoyant et c'est au coeur de
saint denis la 5e compagnie de formation
professionnelle est la seule la la c'est
moins implantée à saint denis
donc ça paraissait important que le rsma
témoigne de son attachement aux
dionysiens